no matter who you are you fall under one
of these three different categories
you're either coming up as a new person
you could be a new real estate agent new
insurance guy new digital market a new
doctor new dentist new liquor store new
deli but it's new in your community no
one knows you you're coming up number
two is your name in a marketplace people
know you if they see your face and name
that's a local real estate agent that's
a local dentist that's a local doctor
that's a local liquor so that's a deli
store down the street but you're a name
you're not the pace setter yet your name
and then there's the front runner front
runners you're number one in your
community in your state in your country
but you are number one everybody follows
your pace whatever you do they follow
your pace you're the lead dog in your
industry in your community in your city
right having said that a lot of times a
person coming up once the kind of
respect of a front runner but you
haven't earned it yet
so you'll hear things are people saying
while I'm busy I'm really busy you'll
hear this word I'm really busy I'm
really busy the word busy has three
different categories in it the first
kind of busy is the facade busy what's
facade busy you're a real estate agent
no one is talking to you you don't have
any clients but no client wants to do
business with a real estate agent that
has a lot of time on their hands so you
have to say what well I'm busy your
bluff in the world I'm busy I've got so
many clients I've got so many problems
let me see if I can put you in a two
clock that doesn't work for me I can do
three o'clock oh you know what I just
had a cancellation three o'clock so
people play this fake busy a tactic that
they play which is fine if you're a
newcomer coming up but you can only do
that for so long
eventually the goal is to actually
become busy when you are busy versus a
facade busy everybody feels the
difference they noticed the difference
forget about the language of what you
say people feel that you are really busy
then third one is you're extremely busy
what does this mean you used to do an
hour and a half appointment now you're
doing 30 minutes now you can't see doing
this you can't see doing this you can't
see doing this used to be on a phone
call that would be 45 minutes now you're
asking if we can make it 20 minutes used
to normally do an hour appointment now
we're doing 10 minute appointments you
should normally write a very very long
email that's a simpler email because you
are now officially extremely busy used
to have one assistant now you have three
assistants now you have an exec you
system maybe you're hiring a chief of
staff depending on what level you're at
so those are two things to keep in mind
coming up name in the marketplace for a
front-runner facade busy busy extremely
busy depending on those two you can't be
a facade busy wanting to get paid of an
extremely busy person you can't be a
common I wanted to get paid of a
front-runner because you haven't earned
that right in the marketplace yet and a
marketplace dictates what's your words
so when you look at this you today have
to take a moment outside of the video
and actually decide what you are worth
in a marketplace not what you think
you're worth it's like how it's kind of
like I think my house is worth a million
the markets is at six hundred thousand
dollars you can say your house is worth
a million no one's buying it this is why
a lot of homes stay in a marketplace for
two years it's been on a market for six
hundred and twenty days why because the
owner thinks the house is worth the
price that the market doesn't want to
pay for so you can say you're worth more
but no one's paying for it I think I'm
about four hundred dollars no one's
paying you as an attorney $400 an hour
you need to start off at $200 an hour
again go back and figure out what you
think you're worth based on market value
not what you would like to be what you
currently are worth then every time you
do a task put an hour next to it this
task takes me three hours I am worth 50
this is kind of take me three hours
that's $150 is it worth my hundred fifty
dollars you may sit there and say yes
because the long term I'm gonna make XYZ
return on this no problem you may sit
there and say no why do I keep doing
this this is a 10 $15 an hour job I'm
not gonna be doing this then you adjust
to a different place